this is going to be a really quick book
update videos so I'm currently in the
Caribbean with my wife we are
celebrating new years away from the city
and in terms of the book quick update
you guys is up name is coming in there's
Nina I have to get the the draft to the
publisher bought you early January and
it's almost done we're basically there
the last part is the last two chapters
of the book I did interviews with people
and was joined by a gin he's helping me
with the book and she took all the notes
and is writing that last section so that
I could focus on just interviewing
people and asking questions and so I
have to look at everything that she's
done in that last section on the plane
ride on the way home then give it to the
publisher and we see how we go from
there I haven't written a conclusion yet
I guess it depends on what stays in the
book what gets cut what gets added as
bonus material what maybe goes into a
next book and then from there write the
conclusion so i'll keep you guys posted
pre-shared love and support usually this
time I answer all your questions but I
didn't bring them with me so it will be
an extra long session next time
answering your questions so that's it
hope you guys have an amazing new
if you have a question about my book the
book writing process leave it in
comments below and I will answer it in
next week's videos have fun guys
continue to believe and i'll see you
soon